on a déjà vu quand même arrivé vers
zigova Adriana Karembeu Carolina curcova
est-ce qu'il y en a encore beaucoup des
filles comme ça là-bas parce qu'on
pourrait aller directement habiter en
dessous de Slovaquie
j'en sais rien il y a une fabrique de
bombasses ou quoi là-bas
Carolina vous venez d'avoir 19 ans le 28
février 2003 ce qui veut dire que vous
êtes né en 1984 à Décines à l'époque
c'était la Tchécoslovaquie alors quand
vous étiez enfant vous avez jamais pensé
à être mannequin votre rêve c'était de
devenir princesse et en fait vous êtes
plutôt
parce que lorsque j'étais enfant en fait
je vais l'air d'un garçon j'avais des
cheveux très courts je regardais j'avais
pas l'air d'une fille je n'avais pas de
boucle d'oreilles et j'avais l'air d'un
garçon vraiment et moi finalement mon
rêve c'était d'avoir les cheveux longs
et d'être une princesse
toujours en T-shirt dégingandé et les
garçons se moquaient de vous à l'école
13 ans 14 ans 15 ans j'étais plus
développé que moi moi non moi j'étais
très maigre j'étais très grande je suis
désolée maintenant je ne sais plus ce
que vous dites c'est pas grave
votre numéro de portable
juste là
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes deux hommes super très sympa
très beau très drôle alors pourquoi pas
finalement
[Applaudissements]
à la première goutte de sang
je rappelle dans des épisodes précédents
Carolina a été très moche quand elle
était jeune donc elle avait les cheveux
courts elle avait les remases elle était
déglinguée les garçons se moquaient
d'elle à l'école comme quoi faut pas
désespérer qu'est-ce qui vous a donné
l'idée de vous inscrire dans une agence
de mannequins à Prague
je me suis pas vraiment inscrite dans
une agence de mannequin en fait ce qui
s'est passé
et comment j'y suis arrivée et bien
c'est qu'un de mes amis
une de mes amis a pris une de mes photos
et après une photo elle a envoyé en
secret à l'agence et puis quelqu'un m'a
appelé en disant voilà alors nous avons
vu votre photo et nous aimerions vous
rencontrer
mais ça c'était le début et puis ensuite
je suis allée à New York et c'est là que
ça a vraiment commencé
Adriana Karembeu Carolina curcova est-ce
qu'il y en a encore beaucoup des filles
comme ça là-bas parce qu'on pourrait
aller directement habiter en dessous
vous arrivez à Prague ma chère Carolina
c'est pas comme les filles de
comment s'appelle
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien qu'on dise ma vanne en
anglais
je suis en train de lui passer vannes ça
c'est sûr
alors c'est donc à Prague que le scout
un scout c'est un type qui cherche des
jolies filles dans les pays de l'Est
c'est ça c'est un mec qui a un foulard
ici avec un béret sur le côté c'est là
que le scoot allait Sandro bansoni vous
découvre et vous emmène à Milan pour les
pour les collections il est là les
Sandro ce soir
bien sûr il est derrière en colis
absolument il regarde attentivement
pourquoi est-ce que ça change tout
parce que en fait c'est aussi votre
petit ami quand même non
Alessandro is not
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment son copain il est vert
mon petit ami que je ne veux pas en
parler qui sait ce que j'ai un Titanic
peut-être
tout le temps
elle a dit son prénom en anglais ça m'a
fait kiffer
à votre avis
je pense que non moi je pense je vais
même t'aider un peu il est sur ce
plateau
vous êtes lancé par James Franco Ferré
et très vite c'est incroyable la
carrière de Carolina très vite vous
défiler pour les plus grands créateurs
vous posez pour les plus grands
photographes bientôt vous allez à New
York et attention à l'âge de 16 ans ça
satoscope à l'âge de 16 ans Carolina
avait déjà gagné un million de dollars
première mineur à faire la couverture de
Vogue USA effectivement Carolina vous
mesurez combien en centimètres
un peu différente
vous aimez les matchs
vous dites Carolina
j'essaie de ne pas penser qu'à l'argent
vous avez beaucoup d'argent
l'argent ce n'est pas la chose la plus
importante dans la vie mais c'est
quelque chose d'important quand même
pour pouvoir faire des choses dans la
vie humaine
merci beaucoup la peine
Carolina est-ce que vous vous rappelez
l'époque où vous étiez pauvre
mais bon voilà classe moyenne normale
nous avions toujours de quoi nous
acheter à manger toujours de quoi nous
vêtir
on va faire une interview si j'étais
pauvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Carolina
Carolina dans quel pays habiteriez-vous
si vous étiez pauvre
en Italie
est-ce que vous préféreriez habiter dans
un hôtel minable ou chez une copine
insupportable
qui est un super appareil
question difficile
[Musique]
parce que je pourrais essayer de
l'embellir un peu je pourrais acheter
des choses pour décorer tandis que si je
dois vivre avec quelqu'un que je ne
trouve pas avoir des ondes négatives
alors là non ça ça me plairait pas
Carolina si vous étiez pauvre est-ce que
vous mangeziez un jour sur deux ou
seulement à midi
seulement à midi du vin rouge pour tenir
le coup si vous étiez pauvre
est-ce que vous soyez communiste si vous
étiez pauvre
non plus est-ce que vous auriez peur des
flics si vous étiez pauvre
maintenant elle laisse tomber leur
oreillette
de voir qui qui va l'emporter pour le
moment une personne s'est levée et ce
n'est pas tiré mais bon Thierry si vous
voulez ramasser mon oreillette
est-ce que vous seriez capable de voler
si vous étiez pauvre
si je pense que j'essaierai d'une
manière ou d'une autre en faisant très
attention est-ce que vous vendriez de la
drogue si vous étiez pauvre
est-ce que vous accepteriez les avances
de vieux messieurs fortunés
si vous étiez pauvre c'est quoi qui vous
manquerait le plus l'argent
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu